hello everybody welcome back to css3 in
30 days today is day number fourteen
almost halfway through all of the days
today we are going to be continuing in a
way from where we left off yesterday in
day 13 which was a sticky footer so
today we're going to be creating a
sticky header let's do it so here is the
info page again like day 13 we have an
info page a student page and a final
page so let me show you what that looks
like the info page here gives you some
instructions it says let's make a CSS
sticky header there are three HTML files
for this lesson index students and final
dot HTML I'll show you that in a moment
you can click this button to view the
student version you can click here to
view the final version so let's check
out the final version here it is you
could see up here the header is neatly
tucked at the top it's got a little bit
of a border or a gradient maybe both in
fact and then when I scroll it sticks to
the top and it's slightly transparent so
you can actually see what's behind the
header so it doesn't actually take up
too much of the screen estate so to
speak in your viewport so when you
scroll it should stick to the very top
when you go back up everything is good
now if I go back to the student version
right here you can see just the normal
header we're going to turn that into a
sticky header it doesn't actually do
anything here so that's your job
slash my job to turn that into a sticky
header so why don't we jump over into
our code editor and let's check out the
files we have the 14 sticky header
folder with five individual files go
ahead and download that folder open it
up in your favorite code editor I
suggest atom or brackets both are free
and some of my veteran students may
wonder why I'm not using coda - I do
love coda - in fact I still use it but
for these types of projects I like
playing around with new software to show
my students that hey you don't have to
shell out a hundred bucks for a decent
software code editor so Adam is my
poison of choice today and I am going to
be opening up my files here so we got
index.html it's very straightforward
this is just the info page so you don't
even really need to concern yourself
with that
final dot html' looks a little bit like
this we have a body with the class of
sticky header lesson that is important
because we're actually going to be
selecting that class you could just
select the body but specifically I want
to select the class we have a div with a
class of sticky header so this is the
header in fact you might even want to
change this to header the header tag to
make it more html5 semantic feel free to
do that if you wish and in there we just
have some text and then after that it's
just some basic content I specifically
put a lot of lorem ipsum in here in
paragraph tags so that the page can be
long enough to scroll it's the only
reason I did that and everything else
down here is just nothing that you need
to concern yourself with student dot
HTML is the same markup we've got sticky
header lesson and sticky header so we're
gonna modify that in our sandbox that's
CSS if at any point you want to refer to
the final code final dot CSS is there
for you right here you can always go
there and check it out now let's get
started sandbox dot CSS let's start with
the very very top we're gonna select
body with the class of sticky heady
lists sticky header lesson you could
also just say sticky header lesson that
would do just fine it would suffice that
the margin-top will be the same height
as the height of the sticky header
itself plus some space so I like to give
let's say the sticky header is going to
be a hundred and eighty pixels tall we
want it to be 180 pixels tall plus some
so maybe 20 extra pixels let's call it
200 pixels margin top 200 pixels good
enough let's go ahead and style the
sticky header now we're going to do is
select the background we're gonna say
RGB a and we're gonna change that color
to 242 comma 57 comma 90 comma 0.9 if
you're wondering where I got that I got
it from Photoshop I was designing this
in Photoshop found the color I wanted
made it a little bit transparent and I
looked at the RGB a color so are the RGB
colors and then I used a for the alpha
the Alpha Channel at 90% so you could
see here 242 is the first that's red G
is green this is the the numeric value
in the degree
scale and then B is 9090 in the in the B
spectrum of the color and then this last
value is the Alpha Channel also known as
how much opacity you want that color to
have so that's why I used RGB a and now
let's go down and we're going to simply
say position thanks now when you
position fix something you fix it in
place wherever you place it based on
your your top value that you that you
set so we're going to say position fixed
and the top will be 0 right at the very
top and the height of the sticky header
is gonna be 180 pixels so remember we
talked about that just a moment ago now
the width of this needs to be 100 pixels
because we're sorry 100% the reason why
I need to be a hundred percent wide is
because when you position fix something
it actually doesn't know how wide it
needs to be so if you look in the
browser here it's actually all jumbled
over to the left so we'll fix that by
simply saying width 100 percent now if I
say that it's perfectly the right width
and you can even see a little bit of the
background there and it is fixed to the
top so it is sticking there but it's
behind everything so we want it to be in
front of everything and we will solve
that with some Zed index we're gonna
change that to 99 that should bring it
up in front of anything that's on the
page and let's finish it off with just a
little detail box-shadow
zero zero 10 pixels RGB a let's go four
zero zero zero and zero point two save
that and that should give it a nice look
the problem here is the text so
everything's stuck to the top and we're
getting on the right track here but the
the text doesn't fit within the fixed
height and that's a problem so all we
got to do is a restyle that so let's go
down below sticky header and we're going
to simply style sticky header h1 let's
start there and we're gonna change the
font size to two point a trim then the
line height to three point two rim
margin:0 auto let's save that and see
what that looks like
looking much better it's fitting within
there now all I want to do is change the
size of the small text so this is the h1
and then this is two small tags within
the h1 I want it to be a smaller font
size so that will simply be sticky
header h1 small and then font size to
rim something a little bit smaller and
that when i refresh should solve the
problem day fourteen sticky header
student version scroll down our sticky
header is looking good you can see that
that 200 pixels right here is the
distance the margin top of the of the
content of the body so that it gives
some space so you have the 20 pixel gap
here to make it look like margin from
the sticky header and there is your
sticky header I love sticky headers I
use them in my websites in fact to think
right now in my blog I have a sticky
header when you scroll down it's just a
nice way to keep the navigation at the
very top your brand sticks to the top
and your navigation sticks to the top
one little tip or maybe challenge for
you if you want to take this a little
step further is use if you are familiar
with JavaScript or jQuery simply when
you have a scroll event when you scroll
down beyond a certain amount of pixels
let's say 200 pixels the distance of
this gap this whole header shrinks even
more in size so that there is more space
to read what's on the screen so maybe
you want to shrink it to half the height
let's say 100 pixels or 90 pixels if you
want to go exactly half you need to
shrink everything the font size maybe
remove the small tags and just have
sticky header so that you could fit
everything and then when you scroll back
up you can have that you know visible
again feel free to try that if you want
I'm not going to cover it in this
because that's specifically a JavaScript
or a jquery challenge but it's something
that I do in my sites
I love doing sticky headers but when you
scroll down if you have a big header it
covers a lot of the screen so you might
want to change that height the
alternative is just to make a smaller
sticky header that's always
to the top now that's it for day 14 the
sticky header I hope you enjoyed that
lesson see you tomorrow and day 15 for
more or css fun
[Music]